because jk rowling
you know she got cancelled because she
wouldn't because she said some stuff
against a um
transgender community do you think do
you guys think the transgender community
is becoming a little bit bullish
they're bullying people to say the
things that they want them to say well
for me it's completely unnatural it's
not even grammatically correct to go
into a situation and go higher my name
is charlie i'm he him because when would
you say that to my face
like it's a these are third-person
terms yeah you know if i referred to you
and you weren't here
hi he got right on my nerves a minute
ago do you know what i mean i wouldn't
say it to his face sarah he got on my
nerves because it wouldn't make no sense
so for me i just don't see the point of
it i think
it's a
you've got a victimhood mentality with
it i don't actually think it's like
a genuine thing anymore i think it's
been
so exaggerated and embellished by people
that want to play this whole woke
politics yeah yeah
you can't actually get away from it now
because if you don't do it you're a bad
guy if you do do it you're playing the
game
i don't play it i don't care personally
i'm not disrespectful to people in
general but if someone says to me you
have to call me this that or the other i
don't have to yeah yeah it's scary
because it's like um i think kevin
summers once said this that
you can either use words to express
reality or create reality before words
were used to express how the word works
but now we're just using all these like
you mentioned about it doesn't even make
any grammatical sense
calling someone by the third person
we're using it to correct reality so if
i say okay if i say a certain word so if
i call myself i'm a super saiyan
referring to a dragon ball z character
does that make it reality for me
that's where we're going to end
ourselves destroying ourselves because
there's only so much toxic tolerance you
can take
new word i always i like that that's
good sorry guys that's good i also think
i think the biggest challenge that i
face when it comes to language is kind
of just knowing what to say and what not
to say i think a lot of the times you
will see on social media people talk
about okay you don't use these words or
you should use these words but everyone
has different preferences and
as someone who speaks a lot in public
it's hard for me to know what words and
what not to use because as some way or
another i will always offend someone
yeah and it's just kind of difficult
finding that balance moving personally
that's something i would say do you
think someone's always going to be
offended yes yeah 100 because we are
different and at some point you need to
realize that you wouldn't please anyone
would you what someone would definitely
feel offended at some point for example
we can just take it from where i come
from there's no maybe there is a
community who is transgender but they're
not out you can't see them in the
streets otherwise where'd you come from
morocco
so it's an arab country right so
whatever is shown in the streets
is
whatever is actually should be shown
from an arab country because if you are
like a transgender you can't just come
out in the streets and be like i'm
transgender otherwise you'll be beaten
up you know it's that serious so for me
for example if you i don't have to to
say i'm she or or he or whatever because
i look like a she right so in morocco
it's i am a she do you look like a she
yeah
i mean like long hair and features etc
that's what i meant right
and in a sense that
you you can't just give yourself another
pronoun
in a country like that because that's
that's what you're meant to be even if
you are addressing yourself as someone
else you know so
for coming from a country like that
you can't just come out
and just say that i'm a transgender
because
do you think those laws are okay
it's not okay completely not because
people who are from that community are
feeling like so oppressed they're not
feeling completely free to express
themselves like they don't even feel
that they're needed in the country you
know they feel that okay we can't even
go out because it's a taboo and my
family has disowned me there are so many
transgenders who came out in the social
media saying that my family has disowned
me i don't have anywhere to go because
this is who i am this is what i am and
even if they go their friends are not
accepting them and no one basically is
accepting them except
that like people like them if that makes
sense right because they would be like
most most of the times families would
just be like oh i did something wrong
that i got a child like you and they
just feel that
what is wrong with me i'm not some like
i'm not doing something wrong to deserve
this kind of like
behavior this kind of you know so
i believe that we really need to work
hard for people to be accepted that way
especially in a country like morocco who
is a completely arab country there's not
like in between either you are she
either you're he nothing in between so
it's very hard to get the acceptance out
so do you actually believe that there's
something in between
um what i believe is
since we are in this generation and this
we're evolving day by day people can
address themselves differently it is it
is it is acceptable like maybe people
would not accept you the way you are but
you are still different you know you
maybe you have something else that other
people don't have so there is something
definitely in between that that's why
people are having it it just can't come
out of the blues right there is
something in between that's why people
are addressing themselves that way but
the acceptance would definitely be
different because not everyone would be
pleased with however you are or whatever
you bring to the community
i think the problem is is our language
you see because the definition of the
classical definition of tolerance was
okay i may not agree with you but we can
live together side by side right the
problem is is that you know we need to
change words so we're thinking because
tolerance was always okay i'm christian
someone's muslim we're not we not agree
philosophically but we are we're still
neighbors we still probably support the
same football team and we're not going
to say i'm going to go to your employees
and say you're a muslim you should be
counseled or expect a muslim to go to my
employee or he said this so he should be
counseled you live side by side i think
the problem is is that as our language
even what the sister
the girl was saying is about acceptance
you know just because i don't accept
something doesn't mean i'm not tolerant
of something so for example if you went
to a neighbor's
house and had dinner you may not like it
but you eat it because you have to
tolerate it
because you want to keep the social
cohesion so i think just what makes a
matter of the language that we we use
and like i mentioned earlier we're using
language to create a forced reality
except expressing what actually is and
that's where the problem is you sound
like you're going to say something i
agree what you said i agree what you
said there i agreed a lot that i think
that people do
accept
you may not accept certain things but
you tolerate them for sure
and i think in a country
like morocco and i don't mean this
disrespectfully
but there's a different
there's a different culture there's also
a different
um
a gdp there like the uk is far richer
therefore
in richer countries you find more of
these kinds of problems
where you have social breakdowns and i
think that
in countries that are poorer
they don't have time for this kind of
mess
if i'm completely honest
because they're struggling to pay bills
or get food or get their kids a doctor
here
abby's biggest complaint most of the
time is the train was late yeah you know
you're saying like transgenderism is
like a first world problem 100
100 where do you find this in other than
first world countries
sorry hang on jess you would you that
you were agreeing over there yeah i was
agreeing because um
it's a it's a big thing in the states um
transgender
and it's just been interesting to see
how like things have changed over the
year
and over the years and when it comes to
just different pronouns and everything
it makes speaking to people hard
because you're now you're worried about
okay
am i going to say the wrong pronouns am
i going to mistake them for
who they identify as are they gonna take
offense that are they gonna not take
offense to it so it's just like there's
so many more stipulations when just
talking to people in general because
even people who aren't transgender use
as pronouns and so you gotta ask
everybody it's just a it's just weird
and different
i don't know sorry guys all right i have
a question when we're talking about
tolerance i agree with that but i think
my question is how how far do we go with
this tolerance because there's been a
scenario i don't know if you guys have
heard but um apparently they're trying
to like
i've seen a post somewhere where it says
that um
all women are allowed into everyone who
identifies as a woman is allowed to go
into um this bathroom you are not
allowed to debate
them declaring themselves as a woman and
that can become very dangerous not just
for women but men like either way it's
very dangerous because um
i remember during 2020 the 2020 lockdown
there was a video going around an
american video where there was a spa
right in america somewhere and there was
a map there was a man with a penis right
who identified as a woman who was in the
female sauna right and he identifies a
woman and the lady there was a mother in
there with her 12 year old daughter
right and she said this guy she came out
ranting like this guy's walking around
with his penis hanging out right but she
was saying that the the um the people
that ran the sauna were saying they
identify as a woman and she was saying
my 12 year old daughter is in this sauna
with a guy that's got his penis swinging
around